first
tickets go on sale next monday
opening act is ted florento and cheers
i love it i love it i was watching you i
was like oh that's it yeah
there's so
some about his early 70s albums there's
like a
feeling yeah or a vibe or something you
just put it on everybody's in a good
mood i think more than the greatest
early 70s outfits
with the donald duck outfits and the big
glasses
what
as a kid he was a prodigy he was able to
play like that right away incredible you
believe that he's destined for that kind
of like chris matthews and sports
chris matthews does sports he was a kid
prodigy have you ever heard chris on
piano yes oh it's unbelievable your own
harmonica even better
all right let's talk another gentleman
you ever heard him on the banjo
look outside right it must be a monday
it's got to be a monday chris right
clear skies outside right now you're
going to see more clouds develop as we
get to the week especially later on the
week more clouds the humidity is going
to go up and guess what we're going to
see storms around the region doesn't
mean we're going to get it right here in
the valley there are chances out there
but there are better chances in some
spots which we'll pinpoint to you in
just a bit 111 the official half of the
day today puts today the hottest day of
the year so far look at that way above
average for this time of the year the
record though on this date was 116. that
was way back in 1959 114 was the
temperature last year on this day we had
a whole string of record numbers last
year around this time 108 currently for
spring valley 109 for you and centennial
hills sky canyon 107 111 north las vegas
the east side of course hotter for you
sunrise matter 113 112
for green valley whitney ranch 108
mountains edge 109 anthem and henderson
coming in at 111 it is hot out there
right now 107 for prep 120 death valley
109 boulder city and often you're
checking 115. so what are the storms
that those are again still focused all
in arizona from flagstaff i'd say all
the way towards golden valley kingman
dry right now but you spelt some outflow
winds from those storms nothing for
clark county right now that high hill
however that's bringing the heat is
going to
scoot a little bit more towards the
north and east of us and as it does that
will open the door to some of the
monsoon moisture making its way a little
more westward by time we get to
wednesday and beyond are there
widespread chances no slight chances of
hit-and-miss storms for us from
wednesday and beyond the better chances
again are going to be focused into
arizona maybe even east clark county
overnight lows are going to be warm look
at your numbers here in the high 80s
across the valley for your morning start
so here's your forecast your overnight
low here's your forecast temperatures
dropping to 88 overnight very warm
lighter winds your high tomorrow 112
this time now we'll put today or
tomorrow the hottest day of the year so
far extra hot and some light warm
breezes your eight day forecast shows
those slight chances from wednesday
through saturday better chances in the
mountains than east and the temperatures
still stay hot that's your most accurate
forecast back to you